in some ways it it sort of collapses
because there's no rules um there's no
tracking of the cash there's no tracking
of the marijuana and when you go from a
product that has been legal or illegal
for generations and you Legalize It In
this case under the med the the medical
marijuana laws you need rules and a
framework and California never had that
and it left not only the state
vulnerable but these individual
businesses vulnerable to
prosecution
hi I'm Zach Weiss Muller for reason TV
we're streaming live from reason TV's
Los Angeles Studios we're here with
Peter hect uh an award-winning
journalist and author of the new book
weedland inside America's marijuana
epicenter and how pot went legit which I
dare say is the definitive history of
California's marijuana legalization
movement from its humble beginnings as a
ballot initiative allowing individuals
to grow few plants in their homes or
backyards for medical purposes to a
green boom that transformed the
agricultural industry of Northern
California all the way to a full-scale
multi-billion dollar industry that
spread across the entire State and Drew
the ey in full force of the federal
government California no longer leads
the way when it comes to marijuana
legalization having been leapfrogged by
Washington State and Colorado what is
hecked Thoroughly documents in his book
The failures the triumphs and the
personalities of the California pot
legalization movement have shaped the
drug policy debate in America in deep
and unexpected ways that will certainly
have effects for years and maybe decades
to come Peter thank you very much for
joining us it's a pleasure to be here at
reason um so the marijuana legalization
in the medical sense was in started in
1996 you open your book book with a 2002
raid though that really kind of put the
issue into the public Consciousness and
and kind of exposed marijuana to people
in and made people think uh in a
different way about it it was a raid on
a Santa Cruz farm that was growing
marijuana for very sick people can you
talk about why you opened the book with
uh that that story it was something that
I came to see as the garden of the Eden
of this story and what you had was a
group of of severely ill patients they
had cancer they had AIDS they had
leukemia they had debilitating injuries
somewhere in wheelchairs and they were
cultivating their own marijuana plants
and they even had wheelchair wheelchair
ramps between the plants and uh they
raised their own cannabis they shared
the medicine at weekly meeting
uh over the years many scores died they
had their ashes uh scattered in the
terrorist mountains above the garden and
um they're commemorated on painted
stones and so forth and this was sort of
the true of the true marijuana patients
Collective but in 2002 the drug
enforcement administration led by a
former US Marine Captain who ironically
had been just returned from an
assignment as an air marshal fighting
terrorism after 9/11 on flights out of
New York City and the Salt Lake City
Olympics they decide to make a stand and
raid this colony and heavily armed
agents uh with battering rams came in uh
they roused a polio patient from her bed
they they arrested a
um a medical marijuana caregiver Mike
carral and his wife Valerie carral who
was a seizure patient who would later
kind of become known although she never
gave herself this title but but pretty
much become known as The Mother Teresa
of the medical cannabis
movement well it was a it was a PR
disaster uh protesters came out some of
the medical marijuana patients blocked
in the DEA Convoy it became a national
news
story um and for days afterwards there
was this sort of national media
narrative that the federal government
essentially conducted a raid on
compassion and it sort of St stirred an
image of medical marijuana as a healing
medicine and it's and the government is
heavy-handed but what follows after that
is dramatically different than what we
saw there and so this story is sort of
the contrast to the billion dollar
industry that develop with retail style
collectives that look nothing like this
garbage
and the entire sort of landscape seem to
change yeah and one specific uh piece of
legislation that came out of that was
Senate Bill
420 um which essentially uh set the
framework for the dispensaries that we
now see all over
California um and uh you say S420 was
drafted with rules as hazy as potm smoke
um how did that the haziness of those
rules uh affect the future development
of the marijuana industry in California
it the nebulous language turned out to
be very dangerous language and opened up
a lot of these establishments to uh not
only ultimately raids by the federal
government but uh crackdowns by law
enforcement because the law was so vague
and the law was inspired by this notion
of a collective and so essentially what
the legislature passed was a law that
said qualified medical marijuana
patients can associate to collectively
or cooperatively grow marijuana for
medical purposes that was the entire
essentially the key phrase in the bill
and on that phrasing soon hung within a
matter of several years a billion dooll
medical marijuana industry in which
retail style stores were
dispensing thousands of pounds of
marijuana and buying thousand thousands
of pounds of marijuana and handling
millions of dollars sometimes tens of
millions of dollars in cash
transactions and ultimately there's
going to be a federal federal backlash
but in some ways it it sort of collapses
because there's no rules um there's no
tracking of the cash there's no tracking
of the marijuana and when you go from a
product that has been legal or illegal
for generations and you Legalize It in
this case under the med the the medical
marijuana laws you need rules and a
framework and California never had that
and it left not only the state
vulnerable but these individual
businesses vulnerable to prosecution so
here in Los Angeles uh we have a lot of
medical marijuana dispensaries and it's
something that has upset the uh local
government here at various points um do
is that directly a result of those hazy
regulations and
um is there anything wrong with the fact
that uh there's so many of these
businesses that have popped
up well clearly in Los Angeles Los
Angeles doesn't do anything in a casual
way I'm an old
Angelino and the city just exploded with
dispensaries and the numbers varied
widely uh 700 800 a th000 the the cliche
was more dispensaries than star
Starbucks but that that
vastly exaggerates the number of
Starbucks um there were were so many um
they were unregulated uh some of them
were professionally run a lot very much
not so much um there were questions
about where the marijuana was coming
from um and every time the city of Los
Angeles tried to do something about it
they would get sued and they kept losing
in court um and
so the funny thing about marijuana is it
seems that the only people that can sort
out the politics of pot are voters the
politicians can't seem to do it
themselves um so la passed a series of
of ordinances and regulations and
ultimately they they got they frustrated
and threw up their hand and try to close
virtually every dispensary in the in in
the city and having patient cooperatives
of three people or fewer or four people
or fewer um and that was over the the
medical marijuana movement race
signatures for referendum knocked that
out and ultimately voters approved a
ballot measure to allow a couple hundred
odd dispensaries in in Los Angeles uh
notably some of the older and more
established places which may or may not
be fair and um and my understanding is
I've heard as we speak there's still 800
to a th000 dispensaries in Los Angeles
so it's going to take a while to shake
out the federal government for a long
time was sending out seizure orders and
any place that the city attorney's
office was looking to close down medical
marijuana establishments the feds were
close behind them with property seizur
over the feds are losing interest in
this battle which is a notable part of
the story and I think the will of the
city is being tested in terms of how
much
it it is able to regulate and and places
can open for a few months and and clear
a couple million bucks they're going to
try to do it so it's going to be
interesting to see what what happens in
Los Angeles but when you look at the
contrast you look at
Oakland Oakland has well they started
they had four medical marijuana
dispensaries I believe they now have six
now mind you one of them harbor side is
the long the largest dispensary anywhere
on the planet do pretty good volume but
the city was able early on to set fairly
strict rules to set local taxes on it so
they were more proactive by the time the
LA got engaged on the issue um the
market was already in runaway mode and
the city is only is constantly been
trying to catch up it's something that's
something that's always struck me as
it's something you hear a lot that it
there's these runaway dispensaries in
Los Angeles but uh my thought has always
been like like so what that's the demand
there's a demand for all these uh
dispensaries clearly so what exactly is
the criticism well there clearly a
Marketplace idea if the market can hold
it so be it um I think the city was
concerned on a number of levels in terms
of law enforcement issues in terms I
mean a lot of neighborhoods didn't want
them near them I as it as it fanned out
it went from business districts more
into neighborhoods places like uh uh
boil Heights you know neighbors were
complaining um they didn't like uh the
Cannabis scents you know kind of you'd
have the the Padia bre bread shop one
place and then and and and the pot shop
someplace else and you know decidedly
different Vibes in that and so there was
a lot of complaints from the nebor those
are natural neighbors though I mean you
hit the panadera after the pat up yeah I
probably should have thrown in the pizza
place too um but cities do have the
right and this has been this has been
upheld by the California Supreme Court
you know they have the right through
local zoning laws to sort of control
what goes where and so that's what Los
Angeles was trying to do and they
haven't been able to figure it out they
you know for a time they didn't want um
uh any dispensaries within so many feet
of of of an alley but the planning grid
of the city is alleys run behind many of
the major and artery so that wasn't
going to work
um and so I guess they're still still
struggling for this so I mean I think
basically it's kind kind of like liquor
stores and there's constant arguments of
some neighborhoods that have way too
many liquor stores other neighborhoods
for some reason have been able to
regulate them out of existence so Los
Angeles is just trying to bring some
sanity to this and they haven't really
been able to do it now voters have given
them the the the the power to do it by
passing which me measure M was it me
measure M measure M was a tax measure oh
okay thought measure M was the and well
anyway voters basically had a choice of
measures one which would have allowed uh
pretty much unlimited dispensaries in
Los Angeles that lost and the other was
to allow
roughly couple hundred or fewer many of
them who would the original dispensaries
in the city and that's what that's what
prevailed so um so that's what they're
trying to achieve this is some sort of
order out of chaos it'll become much
easier for the city if these all become
State regulated and licens entities it
will both take pressure off the cities
and make it easier for the cities to
enact and control local rules you
mentioned uh uh Oakland earlier which
was is kind of the medical marijuana
capital of California and one of the
biggest players in the medical marijuana
uh scene is Richard Lee who you profile
in the book um also the architect of the
failed Prop 19 which would have
legalized marijuana uh for commercial
use uh through or recreational use
throughout the state um one of the most
interesting there were a lot of reasons
Prop 19 didn't ultimately succeed one of
the more interesting reasons was
division within the medical marijuana
movement itself and the legalization
movement itself could you talk about uh
that those uh schisms and and what it
all meant and how it played out well
Prop 19 really splintered the medical
cannabis
movement and part of it started for
reasons of political pettiness is that
Richard Lee was an outsider he was not
part of the original
sort of prop 215 Coalition uh so he was
this sort of interloper who comes in and
so there was resentment on the on that
front there were other people that also
believ it's a practical matter 2010 was
a bad year when 2012 would have a better
electorate with more younger voters and
then there were other people that
complained that um it added laws so
basically it set an age of 21 for legal
recreational marijuana use meaning that
if a 21-year-old passed a joint to a
20-year-old they could be subject to
penalties under the law so a lot of
people were upset with that but a lot of
people were were protecting their
constituencies many medical marijuana
dispensaries were fearful of this uh
they feeled the potential uh changes in
the marketplace from
legalization uh longtime elcd growers in
Humble and mesino County and the great
Emerald triangle in the north uh we're
terrified about prospects of
legalization about uh pot prices
flatlining in this new economy um so
that you there even was a bumper sticker
um uh save Humble County keep potty
legal um and um one of the leading
cannabis physician groups which had an
obvious reason to be concerned about
this
um came out against it saying that it
would it could threaten access to
Medical marijuanas because there were
Provisions in the law that would allow
cities and counties to ban marijuana
dispensaries meaning legal uh
recreational cannabis dispensaries and
people feared that that could be applied
to the medical establishments so there
were multiple layers and then there was
sort of the old soul of the movement
that felt um almost that law was a bad
law and they were they were kind of the
social and political descendants of Jack
her who wrote the infamous movement
Manifesto um the emperor wears no
clothes and um you know alleging
historic historical conspiracies behind
the the marijuana prohibition and hemp
prohibition
and he had before he died um he had
advocated a much more sweeping
initiative freeing all marijuana
prisoners um I'm not sure if this was in
this this particular version but some of
the versions he Advanced were you know
allowing everybody to grow 99 plants and
so forth so a lot of people looked at it
as a politically crafted sellout so it
splintered the movement and
yet heading close into September it was
winning voters embraced it and then
something dramatic happened which was
which was
because Eric Holder weighs in and why
does Eric Holder weigh in Eric Holder
weighs in because he gets a panicked
letter calculatedly panicked from
retired administrators of The Drug
Enforcement Administration and they
basically said look you have to
intervene in this uh Mr attorney general
because if you have sanctioned
businesses in California paying taxes on
marijuana to the State they are
effectively admitting to a federal crime
of illegal drug
trafficking now the letter ignores the
fact that California at the time was
already over colle collecting over100
million in sales taxes on medical
marijuana
alone but some weeks later now Prop 19
was winning in the polls that between 9
and 11 12 points depending which poll
you looked at uh stepen coar was on
television saying that the most popular
in Canada political candidate in
California was Mary Jane Von spliffen
Berg otherwise known as
marijana is how he said it so but Eric
Holder came out and he said the feds
were not going to tolerate legal
recreational cannabis in California now
cut to the present what happened in
Washington in Colorado which as we know
legalized marijuana for recreational use
in
2012 the former District uh uh Drug
Enforcement Administration administrator
sent the same letter to Eric Holder
warning of Calamity of these states
legalized pot uh Beyond medical use Eric
holda didn't respond and I kind of
wondered about that and you kind of look
at the political map well Colorado was a
spring a swing
state so what happened well Obama won
with
51% legal pot one with
55% and the same margin that as in
Washington and then what we had happened
after that was the justice department
moved forward in almost un
unprecedented potentially Landmark terms
of concession where they said okay we'll
step back we're going to leave you
Colorado and you Washington alone if you
run this with robust State regulation
and oversight and they said we don't
want Interstate drug trafficking we
don't want criminal gangs in
infiltrating these marijuana operations
we don't want uh trafficking the
children we don't want uh destructive
marijuana grows Imp parly in the
environment so that's kind of to me it
was kind of kind of the first offer for
for maybe the the end of the drug war
and then we have this action in Congress
most recently where the house votes to
defund the DEA in States uh that have
legal marijuana for recreational or
medical use now I don't think that's
going to go on and ultimately pass but
it it it is in just a few years you see
how rapidly the attitudes have changed
and the the political institutions and
the government institutions are reacting
to that so it becomes a fascinating
story yet here in California the raids
were only amped up uh I mean immediately
in the wake of Prop 19 why did the
federal government react so differently
and so violently here in uh in
California uh two reasons Prop 19 just
sort of revealed to the world and
particularly to the US justice
department what existed here a thriving
billion dooll medical marijuana industry
making cannabis widely available it was
also overwhelmingly
unregulated and um while the movement
talked about compassion and Care um the
FED saw unscrupulous operators operating
beneath this veneer this of medical
marijuana and on one front they were
right there were big farms in the
Central Valley in which plots were
staked with Physicians recommendations
for medical marijuana that were shipping
hundreds of pounds to places like New
York or Massachusetts or Connecticut you
had a dispensary uh here in the Los
Angeles area noo caregivers
where you had people sending Blackberry
messages bragging about all the money
they're making and it was an outfit that
cleared some $ million in three months
and and they were they were shipping
back East they were just blatantly uh
trafficking cross country then the next
thing that the feds targeted were sort
of the business class the wall streeters
um they were professional people who who
tried to follow state laws that didn't
really exist and who tried to be
compliant and tried to operate as
nonprofits which is what the what the
law seemed to
specify and they began investing in
dispensaries and professionally run Grow
rooms ironically what was happening in
Colorado and um but they also started
expanding more dispensaries more
marijuana stores and so the FED started
to go after them and then ultimately the
the raids would go after icons of the
marijuana movement people like Richard
re whose University was was was rated
whose dispensary was rid uh they filed
uh they they rid the model grower for
the the probably most successful local
regulation program in mesino County
where the sheriff's department had
literally sort of tagged and tracked
marijuana plants to try to separate the
Growers operating in the legal Market as
opposed to the black market and they
they raid him put him out of business
and then ultimately they they filed
civil actions to try to Crow down harbor
side which is a case that's still
pending so so and the reason that they
were able to do that um at least other
than the egregious cases of Interstate
drug trafficking was California never
passed laws there was no 10th Amendment
states rights
defense so which has prevented the feds
or discouraged the feds from going in
you know Whole Hog in Colorado they have
done some prosecutions but not nearly to
the same scale so California the
birthplace of the medical marijuana
movement the home of the largest
marijuana economy anywhere never set the
rules they're still grappling over to in
the red legislature as we speak that
left the state not only vulnerable to
Federal incursion but also enabled
numerous local law enforcement agencies
to impose drastically different
rules on marijuana
businesses uh it it's interesting
California's kind of fuzzy
rules uh uh it's always been a sort of
contradiction in my mind the the
entire um the movement G grew out of
this idea of um compassion which I
believe a lot of people in the movement
are very compassionate and that
marijuana helps very sick people but
there's always been this kind of
hippie-ish language of uh co-ops and
collectives and we're not going to make
a profit we're sharing but it's never
seemed realistic do you think that the
is is there sense that the sort
of Feelgood like nonprofit type uh
Outlook from the beginning seated the
destruction later on because yeah I
think it was a it was both a mistake and
oversight
um the clearly the political leadership
had no idea where this was going and
then the more the industry grew the more
they were courage challenged to do
anything about it and I mean in a
perfect world you would have seen um
legislation around 2008 2009 to set
rules for the emerging industry and
that's what Colorado did mean partly
because they didn't want to become the
next California in part because they had
California gondre preneurs as the term
is streaming into Colorado trying to get
into their business so they set very
strict rules um where every medical
marijuana worker in the state was
licensed and criminal background checked
by the state the businesses were all
licensed they had to grow
uh in state supervised uh cultivation
warehouses or green houses all the
shipments were tracked and monitored uh
regulations that were very honorous to a
lot of people in the California movement
but there were regulations nonetheless
that that provided a a working model and
and California became intimidated by the
growth of its own industry now they
there may be a bill that gets out of the
legislature this year we'll see if not
don't be surprised if you don't see
another ballot initiative in which uh
Advocates would just take it to the
voters funny thing about marijuana is
it's very triffin by voters politicians
now this house vote recently was
interesting but politicians by and large
don't like this issue it's not a winner
for them um at at the core of uh any
anti-prohibition movement are kind of
the are the individuals who flout or at
least try to push the laws to the Limit
and a lot of them are documented in this
book whether it's doctors who are
prescribing when they're not sure
exactly with the liw is or uh you know
Farmers willing to grow uh outdoors and
and uh push the limit of plants or
people who are willing to uh talk to the
media or the government about smoking
marijuana and um uh a lot of them risk
prison time and a lot of people in this
book have served prison time um what you
profile medical marijuana growers Dale
Schaefer and Maggie fry and when they
were convicted uh in federal court their
attorney called it a horrible historical
martyrdom um do you think that's an
accurate characterization of how history
is going to look at uh these people who
kind of flouted what may be unjust
laws um well that case in the CR Nevada
Dr Molly fry and and she was a a medical
cannabis physician and she was a breast
cancer survivor her husband was a lawyer
and they were very much Believers in the
movement and
she created this practice where she was
given out medical marijuana
recommendations in a very rural area um
in a town called cool classic name for a
California town it's actually near the
uh site where James Marshall discovered
gold and there was this huge pilgrimage
of people coming up there to get these
recommendations and so far so good
because
um within a year or two after that there
would be a federal court decision that
said uh doctors pretty much had the Free
Speech rights to discuss and recommend
marijuana to their patients there is no
such thing as a marijuana prescription
but they may they can recommend it for
medical use um at the same time
the husband tried to come up with the
system this is sort of pre- dispensary
explosion to deliver cannabis to the
patients and he felt that that was not
only right but but
righteous um but you can't do that um
it's very perilous under federal law or
or state law doctors can't they can
recommend marijuana they can't provide
it to you they can't tell you were to
get it and the irony is and this is a
saga that stretched over years this
couple was being stalked by local
narcotics detectives not secretly in the
open they're they're inspecting their
Gardens they're talking with them
they're yucking it up meanwhile they're
recording the plant counts they're
building a case against them and
ultimately um they were raided by local
authorities and then the case turned
over to the uh to the feds so it was it
was a case that very much was sort of
heartbreaking and sort of a to the to
the movement um but then you had other
people that were very different
different models um that that really did
push the envelope in terms of the size
or the scale of the business and some
were very professional I mean Harbor
Side Health Center for a time in Oakland
alone was handling $22 million a year in
cannabis
transactions um but they pay their
Executives as far as we know fix
salaries they would have holistic
services and naturopathic pH uh
Chiropractic Care
acupuncture uh counseling even
counseling for marijuana dependency and
how to wean yourself so they had they
were kind of almost like the Kaiser
Permanente of weed and so they had a
very professional way of looking at it
and then yet you would have a street
corner
dispensary um handling millions of
dollars of cash and just skimming the
money off the top and you'd have you
know there was one guy in Sacramento you
know making videos uh uh for I think it
was an MTV program who wants to be in
the Cannabis business where you know
he's parading around with wads of cash
he's got a quarter million dollars in
his house um he's bragging about how
much money he made there was an operator
in the S the Orange County Beach
Community of San
Clemente who was kind of the
Shadow uh operator of eight or nine
dispensaries and apparently made in a
matter of years $25 million in cash and
this was purportedly a nonprofit
industry operating as patient member
collectives under California law so
clearly the feds and and local police
saw excesses and they went after it but
then they didn't just go after the the
egregious actors they went after other
people who thought they were trying to
comply with state law so do you think
that we have to accept that people are
going to make money off of marijuana if
we're gonna truly legalize it and make
it
work yeah I think so um I mean the
problem with the nonprofit model in
California which is still being
discussed in the
legislature is it never really specified
what they were supposed to do with the
money right um to some local police if
the mere existence of a bank
account uh would signify profiteering
you know they
didn't they didn't have rules for what a
nonprofit was now Colorado just said
forget it they're marijuana they called
them medical marijuana centers they're
stores they make money interesting
enough the medical marijuana outlets in
Colorado and the ones in California the
prices were a lot cheaper in Colorado
there was competition a lot of places
were forced out of business um now part
of the reason the prices were cheaper in
Colorado and then a lot of people out
here hate was they had an integrated
model where the Cannabis stores raised
their own cannabis or they bought from
other Cannabis stores so it forced these
sort of shotgun marriages between
retailers and Growers and places in
Colorado uh that were renowned for their
pot growing Traditions there's a little
town called Netherland that I mentioned
in the book that's very similar to our
our ukay or Willets or or Arcada uh
those Growers are pretty much shut out
of the commercial market and so
California what the movement's trying to
do is to come up with some sort of rules
and regulations that will basically
uh kind of allow kind of a farm to pot
Pharmacy kind of model where they will
have individual Growers that would be
able to earn an income doing this and
there'd be sort of different tiers of
Taxation at different levels between the
the producers and the Transporters and
then the ultimate uh businesses uh I
think there's a chance it might get out
of the legislature this year and if not
um look for it to be on the ballot um in
2016 so a lot of people are uh in the
movement are optimistic and excited by
what's happened in Colorado and
Washington the there's still the looming
question of what's going to happen here
in
California um do you think it matters
and and what do you think is going to
happen in California and how will
California uh affect the future of the
movement well California is still the
you know the biggest car on the train
right and certainly Washington and
Colorado votes have given a sense of
inevitability that California will
legalize marijuana Beyond medical use in
2016 um I say that's probable it's not a
guarantee and it could crash and burn if
there was again very divided
constituencies in the movement if they
write a a bad initiative which is very
positive
well I very possible um it does have to
have a mechanism I think the average
person who who may not smoke
marijuana um they want to understand
that there's some sort of rules involved
they want to understand that there's
some sort of processes so that you're
not going to have to fear Stone drivers
on the road right that there's either an
effective application of existing laws
or there's some sort of standard for
that Washington has a standard Colorado
doesn't a lot of The Advocates don't
really like the science of the standard
but but anyway I think the average voter
wants to have some sense that it's going
to make sense and so uh that'll be the
key thing for 2016 in California right
now Florida is looking at a medical
marijuana um legalization which could
open up potentially the second largest
cannabis economy of America um so it's
it it's changing tremendously I think
this is going to be played out for
another couple decades but I think very
quickly perhaps in the next couple of
years you're going to see some sort of
compromise nationally in Congress
between cannabis States and non-cannabis
states and and you're going to you're
going to see the the federal government
continue to step back that may all
change depending on politics depending
on election results and the the
constitution of Congress in the white
house but but clearly you got to think
about this Arc of of History we've gone
from
young gay men dying in droves of AIDS in
San Francisco and landmarked medical
marijuana research in California to the
sites of thousands of people many of
them tourists lining up to bip pot
purely for pleasure from in Colorado and
legally doing so and it's all connected
and that's what makes this this a
compelling story and Drew me in as
someone who was not part of the the the
the the marijuana Reform movement nor
part of the marijuana prohibition
movement I just thought as a as an
independent Observer coming in this is a
multi-layered story and and it was
pretty fascinating it certainly was and
is and it's a fascinating book weed land
uh Peter heck thank you very much for
talking to
us